we we want to encourage our members to
submit their games so that we can put
them up here on the slab like carefully
dissect them you know make you all want
to crawl home like what did I do
everything wrong and no we want to we
want to see some fine battles and this
is just a great opportunity I mean I
would like when I was starting this
would have been great you know Lively's
you know here it is to tell me what I'm
doing wrong all right as it may be and
of course for those who've you don't
know we have a very distinguished guest
with us to today I international master
John Donaldson from the mechanics Chess
Club welcome welcome welcome it's very
very nice for him to be here so the
first game we have a cattle hand playing
the Catalan no no cattle and benoni so I
mean I don't even know what to call this
variation of benoni does it have a name
other than fianchetto that's just it
okay so great I I've had this position
as black on a couple of occasions and at
the time that I played this line as
black I should say I was very attracted
to this move b5 because I think a right
and so at the time that I played b5 this
was like the coolest thing and I always
you know prided myself on getting into
b5 before a White's got in a 493 be
stopped and and the line the the games I
had very much went in in my favor
early Bishop g2 d6 and if white just
didn't do anything i transposed into a
line where my pond was on b5 later
some guy I think his name is Casper oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's right
this bar off came up with a move that
was really kind of a great deal of
consternation with this move be fought
before what what white well Gary's idea
was he's willing to sacrifice upon when
wasn't he
for really active dynamic play with
Knight f3 so his ideas he simply wants
to put his knight here one day and in
the meantime it's not like this majority
is doing anything and it was a very
weird idea today a modern chess that uh
the movie for what she just mentioned
was has become like a very principled
move I mean I must say when I played b5
in the good old days if somebody had
played efore against me I would have
thought yeah that guy doesn't really get
it you know he's hanging the pong and I
take the font but my Dutch friends are
in limine yonce mates both think that
efore gives white an advantage and
that's kind of what are you on the game
right so well the idea is kind of
straightforward that okay you take he
takes or as a Queen e2 Queen e2 sorry
excuse me
it is Queen e2 Queen e7 and how does it
go bishop and so like but right so like
obviously a big problem is that if the
knight were to go back to f6 there's a
crook in the corner Queen takes and d6
winds material so if you play Knight d6
is it simply Bishop f4
uh-huh and the idea is blacks pieces are
a bit contorted his night is not
terribly happy on the d6 square and the
Queen's not terribly happy on e7 and the
positions work out very favorably
interestingly enough for white I don't
know the e4 is a computer-generated idea
or somebody came up with that
independently but it sure just put a I
think you know the the move b5 under a
cloud okay but okay black just continued
in the normal style 93 everything is
fine a six a four ninety seven so here I
think is like really the first kind of
key critical moment for black okay so
everything's cool
Bishop f4 Queen c7 I think that move is
okay yeah I suppose I I think Queen c7
makes that it's always a it's all I
think it's always kind of tough for
black in the Benoni to decide where the
Queen is is best placed I've seen a
Veselin Topalov as black and a number of
the Nonis one of the things I've noticed
in his games is sometimes he puts his
queen on e7 and then he drops it back to
f8 it's sort of like the Queen he
reckons that that the queen is better
placed on f8 for specific reasons and
okay Queen c7 92 I like this move very
much white is intending the idea of
nimzowitsch to stick your knight on c4
Knight h5 Bishop g5 I suppose this idea
is white wants to coax black to play h78
yeah it's like your your feeling is that
the pond kinda stands out a little bit
more as a target on the square h6 again
for some strange reason this this
variation in particular seems to bring
out all kinds of exchange sacrifices and
again I kind of recall people playing
moves like f6 Bishop III rook e8 and
rook takes Bishop so blacks trying to
exchange and if black wants to play with
the move f5 which he sometimes very much
wants to do in a benoni he probably
doesn't need it to put he doesn't need h
6 H 6 is in fact a weakness so H 6
Bishop back he does play a 5 ok so
probably it would be if black wants to
play the move f5 he would probably be a
little bit better off doing it in this
way on the one hand you might say well
it's not that big a deal and it probably
isn't but the pawn on H 6 can actually
be in the way in a very funny way again
if we do something very illegal we take
this rook and we snatch that bishop and
we recapture you would probably want to
have the opportunity for Bishop h6 at
hand ok so that's the first thing the
second thing is I know it sounds weird
but somehow I talking I know people
actually really do give up this bishop
from time to time sometimes I just take
this Knight and you know they did they
do it because it means they can play b5
or for some other wonderful reason well
you're less likely to depart with the
bishop on g7 for the knight on c3 of
your pawns on h6 ok so just a few things
there I'm just saying that if you're
gonna play with f5 I don't think you
want to play with h6 and so probably f6
was
better move but anyway okay let's see h6
Bishop back f5 Knight comes to c4 Knight
Knight b6 that strikes me as a strange
move mostly yeah I think but no knees ah
well here's a here's one simple reason
why the preferable Knight e5 is because
after takes if you take the haha having
coax that pawn to h6 makes all the sense
in the world and white would be very
happy munching a pesky okay and this is
actually strategic disaster pardon me I
wanted just to mention that this is
really a strategic disaster for black
oops yes we accept that this Queen d5
Czech Bishop c5 I mean what White's game
is just killing it's killing
okay so that's why we see a Knight b6
night a3 very nice this is also
borrowing a page from Korchnoi many
others white isn't eager to exchange
Knight he's ready to play a five-night
lose and bring his knight back another
thing just in this position one of the
things that white oftentimes consider is
this it's playing an anti positional
move like F to f4 but if it means that
that stops any blacks activity on the
kingside is rather a good move to be on
a list of candidates Bishop d7 I'm not
sure that move really is desirable yeah
yeah you put your night on c8 menu
suffers like you put your night um b6
you sucker you put your knight I mean
yeah man you suffer I think it would
have been in
Black's interest to play f4 probably
you're not interested in in capturing
exactly you probably want to play a move
like Bishop d2 unless just for
argument's sake say in this position hmm
it's probably time I hate this night on
b6 it's probably time to bring the
knight back to d7 this the nice little
difference is in this particular case
thanks to the pawn already being on f4
the pawn on h6 is sheltered right not
that night c4 is required or anything
like that move like III is actually
interesting although I must confess that
at least black is is doing something
he's got a square or two meaning g4 as a
as a potential square I don't like the
move Bishop d7 and one of the things
about the benoni is like there's no
going back
you know I mean whether you like it or
not you know you got to ride the tiger
fro for you know for all it's worth if
black is gonna play f5 any and white is
not playing a move like f4 to stop him
then black just has to go because he I
mean you you can't hold the position
it's like you you've made up a lot of
strategic strategic concessions already
thank you John you've been reading my
books you you know black has made a lot
of concessions and it's sort of like you
can't simply repair them but he can go
ahead and that's why I think they should
be seven I don't like that look
Ruby ate a five-night ooh
b5 I don't think I like that move b5 the
problem is is when as long as White's
keeping his pawn on e - he's not killing
his bishop on G - what I mean to say is
that the bishop on G to x-rays the c6
square you put the pawn on e4 and just
for argument's sake you trade two pawns
then the bishop on g2 doesn't radiate
here when you play the move b5 the c6
square is going to be too weak
maybe bike should have played Bishop b5
here how would we assess this position
I'm pretty sure Walter brown for one
would really like White's position after
for example the small little move b3
he just likes the space of the d5 he
likes the safety King and it's just not
easy for black to generate play it's
like his night on h5 is night on c8 or
poorly placed so this is just a good
position for you but even having said
that I think after your opponent's
decision if something just becomes a
great position for you that was a very
yes oh okay
that's that's a big concession there was
a very nice game it was played let's say
in the last year it was between Vladimir
Kramnik and Fabio on a car you wanna
where it was a Benoni type of thing and
black wasn't really really a lot of
trouble that Amir Kramnik was and I was
just very impressed let's put it that
way would the way car you want to play
that particular gig
now after Knight a5 we can just kind of
stop right here and say
this has been a big opening success for
white I think white just has a very nice
position again thanks to the fact that
c6 is in white Schmitt this pawn on a6
is a little weak and it's very hard for
black to do anything impressive on the
on the kingside fi the forest being
stopped and who knows maybe if White has
everything he'll play rook e1 in E for
one day
advantages across the board for white it
should be five hmm I must say I think
I'd grab that Bishop as well I was just
trying to decipher whether knight c6
immediately or not the difference is is
after Knight okay let me put it another
way if we start with Knight takes pawn
takes knight c6 we're rather encouraging
our opponent to play rook AAA right so
if we play knight c6 first maybe we're
giving them I mean after the move rook
a8 we can always play Knight takes b5
right but maybe he'll play something
like rook e8 or something like that or
roof b7 I'm not really too sure I guess
he would have to play rook e8 in any
case no and then we could take it's just
kind of a move order type of question
like which would be the more accurate
move but okay you took nothing's wrong
and now you went Bishop a5 okay now
let's just see for a moment I suppose in
this position the reason you didn't want
to play something like Queen c2 is maybe
the knight would jump to c4
it's okay yeah it's it's kind of nice
okay I'm not saying this is this is a
reasonable move I always like as white
getting rid of that Bishop on g7 so I'm
thinking about Bishop c3 does just yeah
exactly
all right let's see Bishop a5 Queen b7
Queen c2 night to the side
Knight a 4i
why didn't he play Knight c4 and did you
have a line and mind Bishop C nightís
right and life just goes on from here
well it's a I mean I think it's again I
think it's a very very nice position for
white you've even got ideas I don't know
one idea even is to go b4 and try to
take this guy to get this guy up the
board another ideas maybe to play just
simply efore I like White's position but
9 a four looks a little bit suspicious
Queen B 3 that looks suspicious
I might be a little bit clever or
anything
right well with the milk Queen b3 you're
definitely introducing the threat of
rook takes a four I'm I was just
thinking that this night was a little
off site I thought your intention might
have been simply to play rook a to and
who knows b3 to try to drive him back
Queen b3 I don't know it kind of looks a
little bit awkward and you are provoking
hopefully oh wow Wow
right
okay so let's say so take me through it
what had your intention been after
Knight takes me to a new variation sorry
I just want to make sure yep new berries
par me sorry rook on a one to be one
okay so now I understand that I can't
retreat my knight thanks to the fact
that my queen is hanging on b7 don't
hate that okay but can I protect by
night another way can i play b c c5 c4
yeah and now you've got to I presume
move your Queen Queen to b4 okay so in
this case after Queen before then I can
at least play c2 c3 let's see in this
position maybe you could go Queen c2
right okay so you're still threatening
to play rook takes b2 and once again in
case of c3 Bishop takes c3 looks kind of
deadly I built like blacks chances of
surviving here but maybe after Queen
oops sorry Queen back to c2 for just a
second
Black has some other moves to consider
I mean as mentioning the most a single
most topical thing in any benoni has to
sacrifice in exchange whatever gets the
first opportunity sacrifice to exchange
you know it's in the cards they have to
go for it so something like this at
least from blacks point of view
introduce some sloppiness I mean the
imbalance is probably blacks positions
is not that great but you know white has
to work out some some some tactics I
mean if you take the knight well okay
first of all I could take the rook but
even if I don't take the rook two
connected passed pawns with a good
Bishop on g7 that should should serve as
fair compensation so if I were black
well black kind of committed himself
with the move Knight a for anyway you
almost had to take on V through right I
mean having said a you gotta say B or or
C for beat might be too so look here so
you say he took all of his time and okay
so rook B 1 C 4 yes yes true
I wanted that night on b2 a moment ago
Oates don't now the compensation looks
like no compensation that I can see I
mean if there was a night on b2 in upon
on c3 we could kind of like you know
bring ourselves to believing that you
know there's something some happiness at
least for black so here it's a case of
your well you had to make an awkward
move there right I mean yeah yeah right
it starts to look really good suddenly
so you're in exchange to the good very
good thing yeah
and you're just about to play moves like
Bishop c3e full rook d1 and then you
know try to grab some more material or
do do something to further improve your
position but exchange to the good
you just got to avoid the blunder yeah I
heard the dreaded blunder you know in
the North West John John Donaldson and I
were just talking on our way here we
were saying Victor's Popples Victor's
poo poles of famous famous master from
the Northwest is now playing in rec avec
and rekelen and we used to play blitz
together Victor's and I for hours on end
where he would sing me poetry you know
he said in one of his favorites kibitz
is worse you know like I see a lemon and
a lemon sees me I mean you make a
blunder so you've got to avoid the lemon
okay tonight at 6:00 cream d1 so you're
untangling very nicely here this looks
very nice okay he's doing his best to be
annoying he wants to play b5 before Oh
your curl haha stop the here Oh doesn't
that invite you to play e4 they did very
nice in the way here
well here well here he's got real issues
because this Bishop on g2 which is kind
of dormant if it ever gets on e4 or if
you if you get a weak pawn on f5 Bishop
h3 is going to really be a clinker kind
of move so after E for I think it's now
decisive your advantage as really grown
Oh
raro yeah we have a double attack
against the night on e 8th the pawn on
f5 now you've got ideas like Queen
five in Bishop before as well so I think
this is probably a good time for him
yeah he gave it a rest
yeah very nice I think that was a pretty
good game right everybody yeah yeah yeah
I like that one that was nice
that was well done okay so we have a
game submitted as right it's Peter
yes okay so let's see what Peter this
was from a ladder tournament played here
in in the club and not too long ago
February 25th okay
your white d4 Knight f6 c4 e6 very nice
Knight of 3d five okay Dennis H nice d5
Knight c3 b6 yeah Peter was right now
here black made a move I think that kind
of gets condemned although it doesn't on
the surface appear that wrong b7 b6 yeah
I mean I think for the better part of
you know 16 centuries yeah people have
been playing either Bishop e7 in such
positions or Knight bd7 only after they
put their King in the corner you know
tuck their King over on the Kings side
do they start worrying about b7 b6 and
probably they do this type of thing
because at some moment when the king is
still in the center there might be a
disruptive Bishop b5 check let's see how
this game actually unfolded so b7 b
sixes I think frowned upon but it
doesn't look to be that bad about e3
okay I probably would not have played
III because you know I like to talk to
my piece as an athlete everybody's okay
so when I play the move III I can almost
hear the bishop on c1 yelling you know
get me into the game coach get me into
the game and when I play move like III
the bishop who says to me you know like
dude you know I could have been an
all-star you know I mean I could you
could go to Bishop f4 maybe with certain
evil intentions like might be fine
or the more direct Bishop g5 simply
making the pin as is the usual Queen's
Gambit and to try to put pressure on the
d5 pawn so ii v iii-vi i'm just saying
that the bishop on c1 hate your guts
III Bishop d7 Bishop d3 it's all good
Bishop e7 now I think black can be
reasonably satisfied with this opening
with the outcome I should say of the
opening b3 might be these might be d7
Bishop b2 very good
c5 okay so very normal looking Queens
gambit declined type of position it's
like one of those things that it's like
everybody's willing to accept hanging
pawns should black capture on d4 but
white would likely recapture with his
EEP on the same so takes takes takes
take so white gets hanging pawns and
then in some ways I guess not in this
particular position it takes you could
take with the pawn they're probably
taking what the night is fine okay but
one thing's for sure if you're going to
want to go Queen e2 look see one would
be one
it does doesn't it it looks like it's
transposed into the Queen's Indian okay
normal position let's just say c5 rook
c1 nice development no I kind of like
this move by Black Knight e4 hmm not too
sure I think if I were black I would
have probably captured captured and just
given white what he wants which is the
hanging pawns I'm looking for
clarification in my game
okay so 94s looks okay nothing wrong
with the move Knight e4 maybe my my
approach a little bit of a personal
different okay
I've seen in in very very similar
positions many grandmasters playing this
move Knight d2 it's like it's not that
they're want to avoid trades or anything
like that it's just that they'd much
rather bring their Knight to g3 or in
some cases when I to f4 and they think
the knight can be actually better use on
the kingside especially after black
makes this whopping howler so in the
north yeah in the northwest yeah right
well in the northwest we have this
expression howler to describe a really
really really bad blunder that's your
your your cries of anguish after the
game can be heard in the next County
why did I play fi that's a real howler
because there's a huge huge weakness and
anybody who plays the Stonewall Dutch it
is very very cognizant of the fact that
you know when you've got your pawns on F
defy Vinnie sex you don't leave the e6
guy too weak and now he make sure 90 to
look brilliant because bang Knight
yeah well Knight f4 is just like how
sweet it is you know I mean gift me to
pop and from his point of view there's
no really appropriate rook f6 just
simply walks into it it discovered so
that's not happiness anything else is
just allowing Knight takes c6 so he was
forced
you know necessity is the mother of
invention king f7 not the ideal moving
now you're probably smacking your lips
thinking voice I gotta get to him CD
this looks really good to me D takes c5
now let's see if we take with this
Knight we're allowing this Knight to
jump to e5 with a check we can't take
with this Knight that would hang the
pawn on f5 if we take with the pawn then
your eyes is done takes and Knight at 96
check so you're on the verge of winning
material no this looking really good I
mean and lastly and it's a probably of a
very important American note as well
that if you were to play your Bishop to
b5 you'd be threatening to take and jump
to e5 with a check and a fork so that'll
it's all looking good
oops I guess your move Bishop takes c5
this should be fine that looks really
strong that looks really really really
strong as you say you looking to
activate your Bishop and you're looking
to take this pawn one thing I know this
from my I mean it's not like that these
moves just spring to mind
bubble to mine type of thing but I know
this from a lot of my caro-kann
positions where I get isolated ponds and
things like that one move that I
absolutely have to keep an eye upon is
the move Bishop a six whenever we see
the King on f7 like that
we immediately are attracted the fact
that if we could play Queen takes d5
check our opponents King is in deep
doo-doo right like really really really
deep doo-doo so a move like Bishop a6
really gets my attention because I'm
thinking I'm going to take your Bishop
if you take my bishop then I have to
look at the consequences of Bishop takes
Queen takes check let's say I don't
think there's a choice came back to e8
and now let's see can we play Knight b6
right okay
so with this move I think we have kind
of a multiple number of threats the
first and foremost is I'm an old pawn
Breton pond robber give me your phone
you know like I I want to grab that pot
obviously with Queen and rook
obviously Knight c7 I think that the I'd
be surprised if this isn't a complete
disaster for black and you're not
winning like just like cold like
cold-bloodedly so Bishop b5 probably is
an excellent move but Bishop a6 may
really be you know in the end did you
consider Bishop a6
no okay and again it's just those
considerations that you know from my
years of experience you know like
whenever there's a king on f7 I just
think to myself oh my god Queen d5 now I
mean you know like Bishop Bishop a6 is
kind of a second nature move Knight on D
to f6 well here your Bishop b5 is
looking to
terrific because 95 check is stupendous
he is getting killed
King e7 now here I think it's a question
of different plans of execution what
were some of the moves that you were
considering here what kind of thoughts
well that will impact you of course did
play knight c6 Bishop takes Bishop takes
and he's collapsing all over the place I
mean it's just like one of those things
that you just you're hoping that you've
got some really really great combination
I mean it obviously you're I must it's
be attracted of the fact that your rook
is on the open sea file so you start to
think gosh if I could play b4 he'd have
to take my rook has this open file can I
utilize that somehow pardon me Bishop c6
is also very powerful looking move after
Bishop c6 basically the only move I
really see for black is something like
Queen CA trying to protect the b7 the
bishop on b7 as well as the c6 square
but one of the moves that I would be
really attracted to as before it and
I'll tell you why in this case so first
of all again it sort of like my extreme
desire wanting to punish my opponent for
having his King pulled all the way out
of its lair the fact that that sacrifice
opens up my file but it also leaves this
bishop like for the smallest of moments
kind of like hanging in midair now the
move Bishop c6 really starts to take on
very very strong
impressive proportions because in this
case once again we do see the effect of
the fact that the bishop on b4 is in
midair not to say that you don't have
other things but again my I would be
attracted to be four okay but I like
Bishop c6 oops that wasn't your move
talk me Bishop c6 knight c6 pardon me I
like it
I love grubbing pawns but and this is
definitely a pawn grub so this is all
good
this is all by the way if he had played
before and lost a brilliant game I'd be
sitting here screaming you how could you
not play six and win upon did you see
that everybody he didn't win upon me I
mean what was he thinking I mean you
know like I live for her yeah why didn't
I sacrifice okay so you've achieved the
type of position that all grandmasters
in today's modern chess world strive for
the extra pot and and your upon ahead
and you've got a lot of pluses first of
all you have to to Bishwas but more
important than anything it's the fact
that your opponent's king is still in
the center nine f6 okay now this was an
interesting decision I think many
grandmasters in this okay you have
played Bishop b7 fair enough fine move I
move I think a lot of grandmasters would
have been attempted tempted to trade and
to play a bishops of opposite collar
position why he that that's where people
get kind of waylaid they avoid bishops
of opposite color position because
they've been told and they believe and
they know that bishops of opposite color
in a very dry however in the middle game
which is where we are you're on the
attacking side which means that with the
Queen's on and the rooks and the bishops
your Bishop has no counterpart neither
does this Bishop but since this Bishop
you're upon ahead this Bishop isn't very
good so a variation may go Bishop f6
rook f6 Queen f3 yeah and then your next
move is rook e1 and you're trying to go
after blacks King so I think a lot of
grandmasters would have been tempted by
the move Bishop takes f6 you have played
Bishop b7 okay fair enough
Bishop d7 Queen takes d1 rook F takes d1
tuck-tuck rooks cd8 okay so you're just
going into a nice I and game upon to the
good with the two bishops on your side
as well off you can't a king F one
excellent move centralizing your King g6
I like it I like it you're playing very
well
nicely done kingi to rook David 7 okay
here you made an intriguing move you
played Bishop a6 what's up with that was
there any reason okay
okay so yeah so you so indeed you're
doing everything very well you've played
the intriguing move Bishop a six so as
you've explained what you're trying to
do is keep these pawns locked up right
and then maybe you'll play Bishop b5 so
that you'll try to get the domination of
the D file the question I would ask is
what slowed you down why why didn't you
play Bishop c6 because you do gain a
tempo as well right I mean so you attack
the rook if he trades rook then just as
you've just pointed out you'd be pretty
happy that you know you did your job for
you he gave you that so it's after
Bishop c6 maybe he'd have to move his
rook I'm not sure then your bishop you
could trade rooks or there no I mean I
was just curious if you had a concrete
reason in your mind why you didn't play
bishop seasick
I would agree with you that there's not
too much difference with one caveat and
that caveat is Bishop c6 is forcing I
mean you it that yeah I mean you know
you you do you you are making a threat
with the move Bishop c6 Bishop a6 kind
of in a sense gives them a free hand it
sort of like says if you want you can
move a pawn if you want you can do
something when you play Bishop c6 you
know you got to do something about the
rook okay but Bishop a6 fair enough I
mean we're splitting hairs and that's
fine
rook F d8 nice now I like what you
decided to do which was rook d3 somehow
I like this I mean it's sort of like
you're both being stubborn yes right and
I like the fact that you weren't I mean
right I thought that you were you know
like eagerly trading and you know
something like that but rookie threes a
nice move one of the things don't
underestimate the fact that you've got a
pretty good rook on the C file and if
you were to play moves like a 3 and B 4
well that's C 5 might be the B be worth
its weight in gold that's a that's a
good good file for your rook as well but
I like rook d3 rook takes d3 Bishop
takes d3 night to David five now here
okay
because you had a choice you could play
a three but then maybe he's going to
play a five and you went with roopd one
which seems like a reasonable choice now
I think here he went he went too far
night before is not really a good move
because you can you can deal with that
in many ways I think the simplest is 8th
which is in fact what you played very
good night takes D three rook takes D
three
now you're upon up and you've got ideas
of B for in fact the move before we
before was so electrifying he stopped
you and you said no I actually have two
threats I didn't want to tell you about
that one look look look it over here
look look what I'm doing you got to stop
me got us exactly a nice gear shot that
and he was a gentleman not enough to
congratulate you there I thought you
played a nice game and in this
particular case it's like funny
one bad move f5 getting the I mean boy
boy but black was immediately thrown on
the defensive
you